हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है?
अगर सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है तो
प्लीज चैट में जल्दी से यस या नो बताइए।
हेलो गाइस सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही
है।
ओके थैंक यू एवरीवन थैंक यू एवरीवन अगर आप
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है थैंक यू
थैंक यू तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं तो देयर
आर ओनली 14 स्टूडेंट
तो एक मिनट का वेट करते हैं उसके बाद अपनी
क्लास को कंटिन्यू करते हैं तब तक के लिए
मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि आप सब ने अगर जो
मैं नोट्स आपके लिए बनाए थे उसको मैंने
रिलीज भी कर दिया है इधर इधर जाके नोट्स
को आप रीड आउट भी कर सकते हो मेरे लिंकन
पेज पर मैं रिलीज़ कर दिया था तो तब तक के
लिए आप एक काम कर सकते हो। इनको पढ़ सकते
हो। बिल्कुल जाइए वहां पर इनको पढ़ सकते
हो आप। तो अगर आपको नहीं पता होगा तो
मैंने आपके लिए यह नोट्स बना दिए हैं। और
इसमें दो पार्ट्स में इस नोट्स को मैंने
डिलीवर किया है। काफी डिटेल्स में डिलीवर
किया है। सो दैट कि यू कैन टेक द
बेनिफिट्स। तो प्लीज चेक इट, गो थ्रू इट,
पढ़िए और अच्छा लगे तो फॉलो अप कर लीजिए।
सो दैट कि आपको हमेशा अह नोटिफ़ाई मिलता
रहे। तो तब तक के लिए देखते हैं कितने
स्टूडेंट्स और हैं आने वाले हैं क्योंकि
आज की क्लास के बारे में पहले बता देता
हूं थोड़ी सी हो सकता है आपके लिए टफ
क्लास हो क्योंकि फर्स्ट टाइम यू आर
एनालाइजिंग द ट्रैफिक थ्रू वायस आर्क वायस
आर्क के थ्रू आप क्या करने वाले हो
ट्रैफिक को एनालाइज करने वाले हो जहां पर
हम डेटा पैकेट्स को देखने वाले हैं। खासकर
शिप के जो डेटा पैकेट्स हैं उसको देखने
वाले हैं। तो
थोड़ा सा हो सकता है कि कुछ स्टूडेंट्स के
लिए हार्ड हो। कुछ स्टूडेंट्स के लिए कुछ
मान सकते हैं कि प्रॉब्लमेटिक हो या थोड़ा
सा समझ में ना आए। तो मैं कोशिश करूंगा कि
ज्यादा डिलीवर ना करूं और
कम टाइम में और या ज्यादा टाइम में कम
डिलीवर करूं ताकि आप लोगों को समझ में आ
जाए।
ओके? तो बताइए तब तक के लिए देखते हैं
कितने स्टूडेंट्स हैं। देयर आर ओनली 13
स्टूडेंट्स। क्या किया जाए आप लोगों का
बताओ?
गाइस यू आर नॉट इंटरेस्टेड इन दिस सीरीज।
वॉइस पे टेस्टिंग भी आप लोगों को पढ़ा रहा
हूं। मैं सब कुछ आप लोगों को पढ़ा रहा
हूं। किस चीज में इंटरेस्ट है आप लोगों
का?
मुझे तो नहीं लगता आपका इंटरेस्ट है साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में।
है आप लोगों का इंटरेस्ट साइबर सिक्योरिटी
में बताइए।
सबको आवाज तो सुनाई दे रही होगी।
प्राइवेट तो आप जब बाउंट की आए तो तभी
देखिए फिर आपको अगर इंटरेस्ट ही नहीं है।
लीव इट
क्या बनना चाहते हो?
कोई गोल है? ऐसे ही
तो स्टूडेंट तो है ही नहीं।
ओनली आठ स्टूडेंट।
मुझे तो यह समझ में कि बग हंटर होता क्या
है?
आप लोग क्या डेफिनेशन लेके चलते हो बग
हंटर की? हमें तो वही समझ में नहीं आता कि
आप लोगों के दिमाग में बग हंटर की
डेफिनेशन क्या होती है? या बग हंटर होता
क्या है? या तो आपको क्लियर नहीं है या
फिर पढ़ाने वालों को क्लियर नहीं है।
कोई तो गलत पढ़ा रहा आप लोगों को।
मे बी मे आई या समवन एल्स। इट्स ओके।
फाइन। मुझे पता आप लोग नहीं आओगे। तो मैं
अस्यूम कर रहा हूं कि कोई भी लाइव क्लास
नहीं देखने आया। तो आई विल नॉट सी एनी चैट
बिकॉज़ मैं सिर्फ अपने डिलीवरी करने वाला
हूं। आप लोग कोई भी डाउट नहीं लेने वाला
क्योंकि मेरी तरफ से कोई नहीं आया क्योंकि
स्टूडेंट्स आए ही नहीं है। जो भी डिवाइसेस
है मेरे ही डिवाइस है। बाकी ज्यादा कोई
आया नहीं है। इट्स ओके फाइन। तो चलिए
यह मैंने शेयर कर दिया था आप लोगों को।
मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
आज हम बात करने वाले हैं कि लास्ट क्लास
में मैंने आपको बताया था कि
शिप कॉल फ्लो कैसा होता है या शिप हैंड से
कैसे होता है? जस्ट कुछ इमेज के थ्रू
मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन किया था। मैं आपको
बता देता हूं। यह सब चीजें मैंने आपको
क्लियर की थी। यह चीज मैं आपको बता चुका
था। लास्ट क्लास में मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन
किया था। यह सब चीजें कि इनवाइट मैसेज
होता है। देन उसके बाद मैंने आपको
एक्सप्लेन किया था कि 302 स्टेप टू स्टेप
थ्री देन उसके बाद में एक्सप्लेन स्टेप
फोर स्टेप फाइव यह सारी चीजें मैं
एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं। वन बाय वन आपको
शोकेस कर देता हूं। सो दैट कि
आपको कंफ्यूज ना रहे या कंफ्यूजन ना रहे
कि हमने क्या पढ़ा था और इसी चीज को मैं
प्रैक्टिकली आपको शो करने वाला हूं। जस्ट
सिनेरियो बेस मीडिया आरटीपी सेटअप हो गया
था। तो हम सारी चीजें देखने वाले हैं और
मैंने आपको बताया था कि रजिस्ट्रेशन
प्रोसेस भी होती है एक कॉलर ए और
रजिस्ट्रार के बीच में सर्वर के बीच में
जिसमें वे तीन से चार स्टेप में प्रोसेस
होती है। उसके बाद आपका शिप हैंडशक होता
है। तो अभी हम बात करने वाले हैं वो है
हमारा कि सबसे पहले हम देखेंगे कि हमारा
एग्जांपल यह है सिनेरियो यह है कि एक यूजर
वन है। एक यूजर है। एलइस बोल एल में
प्रोनाउंस में इशू हो सकता है। एल और bob
दो यूज़र्स हैं। बीच में आपका शिप सर्वर
है। यह शिप सर्वर का IPपी एड्रेस है। यह
आपका IPपी एड्रेस है एल यूज़र्स का। यह
आपका बॉब यूजर का है। यह उसकी आईडी है 11
1 यह इसकी यूजर आईडी है 222। यह इसका
पासवर्ड है। यह इसका पासवर्ड है। तो, हम
बिल्कुल स्टेप बाय स्टेप देखने वाले हैं
कि सबसे पहला स्टेप क्या होता है?
रजिस्ट्रेशन प्रोसेस कि सबसे पहले क्या
होता है? रजिस्टर होता है। तो रजिस्ट्रेशन
प्रोसेस होती कैसे है? प्रैक्टिकली मैं
आपको शो करता हूं कि मैं आपको एक-एक पैकेट
को रिप्रेजेंट करूंगा। एक-एक पैकेट को शो
करने वाला हूं प्रैक्टिकली। उसके बाद मैं
आपको एक्सप्लेन करूंगा कि आपका
शिप हैंडशक होता कैसे है। तो चलिए हम एक
काम करते हैं। अपने वसआर पे चलते हैं और
शिप आरtp के फोल्डर पे मैं चलता हूं और
आपको मैं दिखा देता हूं। इसको वसार के
अंदर ओपन करता हूं। चलो इट्स ओके फाइन।
जस्ट इट विल टेक वन और टू मिनट। ओके, मैं
इसको अभी क्लोज कर देता हूं। इसने ऐसे ही
रैंडम ओपन कर दिया। अभी मैं इसको ये रहा।
चलो यह हमारे पैकेट्स हैं। हम अस्यूम कर
रहे हैं कि हमने जो आपको एग्जांपल शो करना
है वह इस तरीके से है कि जो यूजर वन है जो
एलस है और दूसरा यूजर टू है जिसका नाम है
बॉब है। दोनों के पैकेट हमने कैप्चर किए
हैं और उसको उसकी पिक फाइल को हम एनालाइज
कर रहे हैं। कोच आपको सारी चीजें क्लियर
हो जाए वन बाय वन स्टेप बाय स्टेप कि कैसे
चीजें एनालाइज हो रही हैं, कैसे चीजें काम
करती है, कैसी चीजें दिखती हैं, कैसे
पैकेट दिखाई देते हैं। तो अभी आपको मैं
आपको शो करूं, तो हम चलते हैं पहले
टेलीफ़ोनिक के अंदर चलते हैं। टेलीफ़ोनिक के
अंदर शिप फ्लो के ऊपर चलते हैं। दीज़ ऑल आर
योर शिप पैकेट्स। और एक काम और कर लेते
हैं हम। यहां पर एक फ़िल्टर लगा लेते हैं
कि हम अभी नहीं लगाते। फ़्टर अभी लगाने की
जरूरत नहीं है वैसे हमें। तो, इज़ माय
सेकंड यह रहा। तो यहां पर चलते हैं हम और
यहां पर कंट्रोल ऑल करते हैं। इसको
सेलेक्ट कर लेते हैं। कंट्रोल ऑल सेलेक्ट
किया और हम क्या करते हैं? फ्लो सीक्वेंस।
यह हमारा सीक्वेंस फ्लो है। इसको हम पीछे
वाला क्लोज कर देते हैं। यह कंप्लीट है।
तो यहां पर देख पा रहे हो आप। यह 192 168
20 132 यह है 192 168 20 130 192 168 21
यह आपका सर्वर है। यह आपका यूजर अह कॉलर
वन बोल सकते हो। यह आपका कॉलर टू है जिसको
हम एग्जांपल के लिए बोल सकते हैं या बॉब
बोल सकते हो। यह आपका बॉब यूजर है। यह
आपका एलआई आपका जो यूजर है यह आपका शिप
सर्वर है। यहां पर देखोगे तो यहां पर आप
देखोगे रजिस्टर 401 अन ऑथराइज़ रजिस्टर 200
ओके जैसे मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन किया था।
सेम यहां पर रजिस्टर 401 रजिस्टर 200 ओके।
चलो आपको यह देखने को मिल गया। उसके बाद
यह देखोगे इनवाइट ये सारी चीजें होते की
है। मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं वन बाय
वन इस पूरे पैकेज को और काफी डिटेल में
एक्सप्लेन करने वाला हूं बिल्कुल स्टेप
बाय स्टेप बिल्कुल वन बाय वन चीजें आपको
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा ताकि आप लोगों को
बिल्कुल चीजें क्लियर हो जाए। तो शायद ये
सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा होगा या इसको
मैं ज़ूम करता हूं। ज़ूम होगा तो इसको देखते
हैं। 1 मिनट
बिल्कुल यह ज़ूम हो गया। तो इतना ही ज़ूम
होगा और इसको हम एक काम करते हैं। अभी
छोटा कर लेते हैं और यहां पर मिनिमाइज
करते हैं। और अभी हम चलते हैं यह हमारा
पैकेट बाय पैकेट इस चीज को हम देखने वाले
हैं। और स्टार्ट करेंगे वन बाय वन। तो
यहां पर इसको अप कर लेते हैं। और नाउ गो
टू दिस पैकेट। और सबसे पहले जो पैकेट
देखने वाले हैं, यह आपका रजिस्टर पैकेट
है। कहां पर? 56330 से। और एक काम इससे भी
पहले हम एक और एक और काम करते हैं। इसका
इससे पहले हम क्या काम करते हैं कि यह रहा
इस पैकेट है दिस वन। अब इसको मिनिमाइज
करते हैं हम और इनका नाम ही रख लेते हैं।
सो दैट कि आपको चीजें क्लियर हो जाए। 132
आपका क्या है? कॉलर वन है। यूजर वन है। तो
हम इसको बहुत ही आसानी से कर सकते हैं। एक
काम कर सकते हैं राइट क्लिक करेंगे इसके
ऊपर। सोर्स के ऊपर राइट क्लिक किया। राइट
क्लिक एडिट रिजॉल्व नेम और जैसे हम इसको
करेंगे नेम रेोल्यूशन प्रेफरेंस। इसके ऊपर
जाएंगे तो क्लिक करेंगे हम यहां पर
अनक्लिक मिलेगा यह रिजोल्व नेटवर्क आईपी
तो इसको क्लिक करना है वैसे इसके किसके
अंदर नेम रेोल्यूशन के अंदर नेम रेोल्यूशन
रिजोल्व नेटवर्क आईपी एड्रेस इसके ऊपर
क्लिक होना चाहिए आपका अप्लाई करोगे ओके
करोगे उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है जब 132
है आपका 192 168 20 132 इस पे फिर से आप
जाओगे फिर राइट क्लिक करोगे एडिट रिजॉल्व
नेम और यहां पर आप नाम रख सकते हो जो रखना
चाहते हो फॉर एग्जांपल मैं रख रहा हूं
कॉलर वन वन या हम रख सकते हैं कॉलर
ए रख सकते हो या शॉर्ट ब्रैकेट में आप रख
सकते हो एलआई या हम बोल सकते हैं आप कॉलर
ए रख सकते हैं हम कॉलर ए इसका नाम रख देते
हैं और या हम जो हमारे स्लाइड में था वो
भी रख सकते हैं एलाइस या हम बॉब रख सकते
हैं ट्विस्ट हो के हम कॉलर ए रख लेते हैं
इसको और ओके किया तो अब यहां पर देखो यहां
पर क्या नाम आ रहा है कॉलर ए उसके बाद हम
रख रहे हैं यह आपका सर्वर है
192.168.20.130
इसको भी राइट क्लिक करते हैं। एडिट रिजोल
नेम और यहां पर नाम रखते हैं हम सर्वर।
सर्वर का नाम रख दिया इधर ओके। यह आपका
सर्वर है डेजिग्नेशन पे। अभी एक और है
हमारा A20 है हमारे पास। एक और वन आईपी
एड्रेस होगा। यह रहा दिस वन कि अभी इससे
हमारा फ्लो काफी इजी हो जाएगा। एडिट रिजोल
नेम। यहां पर हम क्लिक करते हैं। हम रखते
हैं कॉलर।
कॉलर बी हमने यहां पर नाम रख दिया। कॉलर
बी नाम रख दिया हमने इट्स ओके। चलिए यह
कॉलर बी हो गया। तो हमने सब कुछ कर लिया।
अब एक काम करते हैं। हम फिर से इनको क्लोज
करते हैं। यहां पर नाम आ गया। यह देखो देख
पा रहे हो कॉलर ए सर्वर कॉलर बी। अब आपको
आईडिया मिल गया कि हम किसके बीच में
क्या-क्या एनालाइज करने वाले हैं। तो हम
सबसे पहले चलते हैं फर्स्ट ब्रैकेट पर।
यहां पर क्लिक किया। यहां आप क्लिक कर
सकते हो। जैसे यहां क्लिक करोगे यहां पर
सेलेक्ट हो जाता है। देखो यहां क्लिक
किया। यहां क्लिक किया। तो यहां मैंने
क्लिक किया और मैं एक काम करता हूं। इसको
ऊपर की तरफ कर लेता हूं। यह रहा बिल्कुल
और यह हमारा फर्स्ट पैकेट था। मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं। यह रहा तो यहां पर क्लिक
किया। यह आपका फर्स्ट पैकेट है। तो मैं
इसको एनालाइज करके दिखाऊं। तो यह रहा आपका
तो आप देखोगे यूजर डाटाग्राम प्रोटोकॉल
सोर्स पोर्ट और डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट। तो यह
क्या है आपका? यह आपका पहला शिप रजिस्टर
मैसेज है। आपको पता है। यह कौन सा आपका
है? पहला शिप रजिस्टर मैसेज है। रजिस्टर
का मतलब क्या होता है? आपको पता है कि जो
शिप क्लाइंट है अपने आप को शिप सर्वर के
पास रजिस्टर कर रहा है। यह उस टाइम का जो
मैसेज है जहां पर आपको मैंने दिखाया था
रजिस्टर रिक्वेस्ट है कि रजिस्टर मैसेज का
मतलब क्या होता है? जब शिप क्लाइंट शिप
सर्वर के साथ अपने आप को रजिस्टर करने की
कोशिश करता है, तब इसका यूज़ किया जाता
है। तो, एक काम करते हैं। अभी यह देखते
हैं। यूजर यूडीपी ठीक है? यह आपका
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर है। यह आपका ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर प्रोटोकॉल है। यहां ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
देखोगे तो यह किसका यूज़ कर रहा है? यूडीपी
का यूज कर रहा है। और यहां पर सोर्स पोर्ट
कौन सा आपका? 56330
डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट आपका 5060 बाय जो
डेस्टिनेशन 5060 क्या होता है? बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट पोर्ट आता है आपका अनइंकिप्टेड
फॉर्म में। किसके लिए? वाइप के लिए। उसके
बाद अब आ गया आपका शिप सेशन इनिशिएशन
प्रोटोकॉल। यह आपका रजिस्टर मैसेज है।
रजिस्टर हेडर आपका शिप हेडर है। जो मैं
आपको बताया था ना कि http की तरह शिप के
हेडर्स भी होते हैं। तो यह सबसे पहला आपका
शिप हेडर है। मैं इसको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं
और मैं इसको क्लोज करके ये रहा आपका।
इसमें दो हैं। दो चीज़ एक तो रिक्वेस्ट
लाइन है जो सबसे पहले आपकी स्टार्टिंग
लाइन है। दूसरा आपका मैसेज हेडर है। तो
रिक्वेस्ट लाइन को मैं देखो एक-एक चीज
करके मैं बिल्कुल प्यार से आपको समझाने की
कोशिश करूंगा। आपको समझ में आए तो मैं
आपको पूछूंगा फिर भी। तो देखो रिक्वेस्ट
लाइन में क्या है आपका? रजिस्टर शिप 192
168 20 130 शिप 2.0 तो यहां पर देखोगे आप
मेथड कौन सा यूज़ किया जा रहा है? रजिस्टर
मेथड मतलब मेथड कौन सा आपका? रजिस्टर है।
रिक्वेस्ट यूआरआई यह आपका रिक्वेस्ट यहां
पर क्या है? शिप क्लाइंट कह रहा है कि
प्लीज मुझे सर्वर पर रजिस्टर कर दो। यह जो
आप किसके पास रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहा है? शिप
के पास। रजिस्टर रिक्वेस्ट है और सर्वर को
बोल रहा है प्लीज मुझे रजिस्टर कर लो। और
टारगेट
रिक्वेस्ट यूआरआई के अंदर आप देखोगे कि यह
किसका IPपी एड्रेस है? यह आपके सर्वर का
IPपी एड्रेस है। किसका IPपी एड्रेस है? यह
शिप सर्वर का IP एड्रेस है। तो ये शिप
सर्वर को बोल रहा है कि मुझे सर्वर पर
रजिस्टर कर दो। और कौन सा शिप वर्जन यूज़
हो रहा है? 2.0
2. तो कहने का मतलब यह है कि जो फोन है
अपने आप को सर्वर के पास लिस्ट कर रहा है
ताकि वह कॉल को रिसीव कर सके। यह फर्स्ट
पैकेट यही बोल रही है जो रिक्वेस्ट लाइन
है। देन उसके बाद आता है आपका मैसेज हेडर।
अब मैसेज हेडर में बहुत सारी चीजें हैं।
वाया फ्रॉम टू कमांड सीक्वेंस कांटेक्ट
एक्सपायर्स, अलव कंटेंट लाइन। यह शायद जी
मैं आपको बताई थी कि इतने सारे हैडर्स भी
होते हैं। तो, सबसे पहले हम चलते हैं
मैसेज हेडर के ऊपर। सबको अह थोड़ा सा वह
ज़ूम करना है या दिखाई दे रहा है बताओ?
सब ज़ूम करना है या दिखाई दे रहा है बताओ?
सबको ज़ूम दिखाई दे रहा है।
सबको बिल्कुल क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है।
या थोड़ा सा जूम करना है। बताओ।
ओके। तो, जैसे यहां देखोगे, यह आपका क्या
है? वाया हेडर है। इसके अंदर है shif 2.0
यूडीp ट्रांसपोर्ट पोर्ट कौन सा है?
यूडीपी का यूज़ किया जा रहा है। यहां पर
क्या है? सेंट बाय एड्रेस कि जो क्लाइंट
का आईपी कौन सा है? क्लाइंट का आईपी क्या
है? 192.168.20132
क्लाइंट का आईपी है। यह आपका 56330 किसका
है? क्लाइंट का पोर्ट है। ट्रांसपोर्ट
आपको पता है यूडीपी का यूज किया जा रहा
है। आर पोर्ट आर पोर्ट का मतलब क्या होता
है कि जो शिप सर्वर जब भी इस यह बोल रहा
है कि यहां पर नेट का यूज़ किया जा रहा है
नेटवर्क एड्रेस ट्रांसलेशन का कि यहां पर
यह बोल रहा है कि अगर शिप सर्वर को मेरे
को रिप्लाई करना है आर पोर्ट का मतलब यहां
पर यह है अगर शिप सर्वर को या किसी को भी
मेरे को रिप्लाई करना है तो इसी पोर्ट पर
रिप्लाई करना है। अभी के लिए इसने यही
बोला है इस रिक्वेस्ट में मुझे अगर
रिप्लाई करोगे तो आप चाहे ओके मैसेज करो
फेलियर मैसेज करो तो आप मेरे को कौन से
पोर्ट पे रिप्लाई करोगे 56330 पे ही आप
मेरे को रिप्लाई करोगे उसके बाद आपका जो
ब्रांच है इसका मतलब क्या है यह आपका एक
यूनिक ट्रांस ट्रांजैक्शन आईडी है जैसे
जैसे आप http में आपने अगर रिक्वेस्ट देखी
होंगे एचटीटीपी की रिक्वेस्ट की आईडी होती
है सेम उसी प्रकार से शिप में भी ब्रांच
आईडी वही सेम यूनिक ट्रांजैक्शन आईडी होती
है बिल्कुल बिल्कुल उसी की तरह। ओके? तो,
यह चीज सबको समझ में आ गई कि कौन यह
क्लाइंट का आईपी है। क्लाइंट का पोर्ट है।
क्लाइंट बोल रहा है कि आपको मेरे को
रिप्लाई करना है, तो प्लीज इसी पोर्ट पर
मुझको रिप्लाई कीजिए। यह उसका यूनिक
ट्रांजैक्शन आईडी है लाइक एचटीटीp। उसके
बाद मैक्सिमम फॉरवर्ड्स क्या होता है? यह
बिल्कुल टीटीएल की तरह है। इंश्योर करता
है कि जो आपका मैसेज है इनफाइनाइट लूप में
ना फंसे। जो आपका नेटवर्क है नेटवर्क में
इनफाइनाइट लूप में ना फंसे। मतलब कि हर
बार जब भी यह क्या करेगा अह जब भी किसी एक
प्रॉक्सी के पास या जब भी किसी के पास
जाएगा तो इसकी वैल्यू कम होती जाएगी।
जिससे क्या होगा कि कंटीन्यूअसली ट्रेवल
नहीं करता रहेगा यह कंटिन्यूसली ट्रैक में
रहेगा पैकेट और जैसे इसकी वैल्यू ज़ीरो हो
जाएगी वहीं पर ड्रॉप हो जाएगा। तो इसका
मतलब यह है लाइक टीटीएल वैल्यू। सबको पता
है टीटीएल का केस कैसे होता है। उसके बाद
आता है आपका फ्रॉम हेडर। उसके बाद आता है
आपका फ्रॉम हेडर। फ्रॉम हेडर में देखोगे
आप ये रहा। तो यहां पर शिप 1 1 फॉर टाइम
1@ 192 168 इसका मतलब क्या है? यहां पर
मैं वन बाय वन समझाता हूं। यहां पर क्या
है कि जो शिप यूजर है यूजर कौन है? जो
आपका कॉलर ए है। कॉलर ए क्या कर रहा है?
इस आईडी से उसकी यू यूजर का जो आईडी है या
यूजर नेम बोल सकते हैं जिसको क्योंकि
टेलीफोन के केस में मतलब फोर डिजिट या
फाइव डिजिट या सिक्स डिजिट व्हाटएवर कोई
ना कोई तो नंबर ही होगा कॉल करने के लिए।
यहां पर क्या है? चार डिजिट का एक नंबर
यूज़ किया जाता है। मतलब यह उसका यूजर
पार्ट है। तो जो यूजर है जो क्लाइंट है वो
बोल रहा 11 1 यह क्लाइंट क्या है? रजिस्टर
करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। किसके साथ?
किसके साथ? इस शिप सर्वर के साथ
192.168.2030
इस शिप सर्वर एड्रेस के साथ। यह उसकी
रजिस्टर
क्लाइंट यूजर की आईडी है और इस यू सर्वर
के साथ क्या करने की कोशिश कर रहा है?
रजिस्टर करने की कोशिश कर रहा है। ओके।
उसके बाद देखोगे शिफ्ट फ्रॉम टैग। अभी
यहां पर यह टैग है। यह आपका एक रैंडम आईडी
है ताकि आपकी जो रिक्वेस्ट है उसमें
यूनिकनेस बनी रहे। यह रैंडम आईडी है। तो,
आपको पता चल जाएगा। जैसे-जैसे आप
रिक्वेस्ट पढ़ोगे, आपको पता चल जाएगा। तो,
यहां पर तीन चीजें हैं। एक तो क्या है? जो
क्लाइंट की आईडी क्या है? 11 1 शिप यह
क्या सर्वर जिसके साथ रजिस्टर करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है। तो इसका मतलब यह है
फ्रॉम हेडर का आई एम यूजर 111 एंड आई वांट
टू आई वांट टू रजिस्टर ऑन 192.168.20.130
के साथ मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं? मैं सो
यूजर हूं और मैं इस शिप सर्वर IPपी एड्रेस
के साथ रजिस्टर करना चाहता हूं। तो यह है
इस इस लाइन का मतलब फ्रॉम लाइन का।
नेक्स्ट आ गई आपकी इसके अंदर टू हेडर है।
इसके अंदर आपका टू हेडर है और बिल्कुल
आपको सिमिलर दिखाई देगा। देखो शिप हेडर
सेम सेम। अभी यहां पर ये तीन चीज़ आपको बता
देता हूं। ये ये तीन चीजें टू के अंदर
जो जब भी आप रजिस्टर मैसेज की बात करते हो
उसमें फ्रॉम और टू दोनों सेम होते हैं।
रजिस्टर मैसेज जो भी होते हैं उनके अंदर
फ्रॉम और टू बिल्कुल सिमिलर होते हैं।
क्यों? क्योंकि
जो आपका यूजर है वह खुद को ही रजिस्टर कर
रहा है। आपका जो यूज़र्स है जो आपका
क्लाइंट है वह खुद को रजिस्टर कर रहा है।
इसलिए क्या है? दोनों के दोनों क्या है?
सेम ही हैं। अब यह चीज समझ में आ गई फ्रॉम
और टू। नेक्स्ट यहां पर एक इंपॉर्टेंट
पैरामीटर है या एक इंपॉर्टेंट हेडर की बात
करें। कॉल आईडी है। अब यह कॉल आईडी क्या
होता है? कॉल आईडी काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
कॉल आईडी एक यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर है आपकी
रजिस्ट्रेशन रिक्वेस्ट के लिए। आपकी
रजिस्ट्रेशन जो अटेम्प्ट है उसके लिए यह
एक यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर है। और हर कॉल या
रजिस्ट्रेशन के लिए क्या है? यह अलग होता
है। हर हर कॉल या रजिस्ट्रेशन के लिए कॉल
आईडी अलग होगी। अगर वह अलग रिक्वेस्ट होगी
तो समझने की कोशिश करो। क्या बोल रहा हूं
मैं कि हर कॉल आईडी यह जो कॉल आईडी है हर
एक रिक्वेस्ट की अलग होगी।
हर रिक्वेस्ट की क्या होगी? कॉल आईडी
बिल्कुल अलग होगी। तो समझ में आ गया सबको
कि इसका मतलब क्या है कॉल आईडी का?
ओके। तो कॉल आईडी जब भी आप रजिस्ट्रेशन
अटेम्प्ट किया जाएगा यह कॉल आईडी डिफरेंट
होगी लेकिन अलग के लिए। नेक्स्ट उसके बाद
आप देखोगे यह रहा सी सीक्वेंस। यह क्या
आपका कमांड सीक्वेंस है। यह आपका क्या है?
कमांड सीक्वेंस है। यह एक सीक्वेंस नंबर
होता है। किस रजिस्टर मेथड के लिए जो आपका
रज किस कौन से मेथड के लिए क्या सीक्वेंस
नंबर यह मेंटेन किया जाता है। और यह क्या
होता है कि जैसे ही आप एक और रिक्वेस्ट
भेजोगे तो इसको में +1 ऐड कर दिया जाएगा।
इसमें क्या किया जाए? सीक्वेंस वैल्यू में
+1 ऐड कर दिया जाएगा। अगर रजिस्टर दोबारा
करने की कोशिश करेगा। इसका भी कारण मैं
बताऊंगा क्यों क्यों होगा। उसके बाद यह
यूजर एजेंट है। यूजर एजेंट का मतलब क्या
है? एप्लीकेशन कौन सी क्लाइंट एप्लीकेशन
का है जिसके थ्रू कोशिश कर रहा है जैसे कि
हम क्या करते हैं http के केस में होता है
ब्राउज़र को यूज करते हैं तो वहां पर यूजर
एजेंट होता है सेम इसी में यूजर एजेंट
होता है इसमें माइक्रो शिफ्ट का यूज़ किया
है उसका वर्जन के साथ तो यहां पर क्या है
microsoft सॉफ्ट फोन का यूज़ किया जा रहा
है उसका वर्जन और उसके टाइप के साथ उसके
बाद है आपका कांटेक्ट यह रहा आपका के अंदर
क्या है आपके कांटेक्ट यूआरआई मतलब इसके
अंदर क्या है जो कांटेक्ट हेडर है सर्वर
को यह बोल रहा है कि अगर किसी को मुझे कॉल
करना है। अगर कोई मेरे को कॉल करना चाहता
है मतलब कॉलर ए को या एलआई यूजर को तो वह
इस एड्रेस पर कॉल करें। किस पे? 11 1 इस
IPपी एड्रेस पे इस पोर्ट पर। यह आपका
फिक्स कुछ
स्टैंडर्ड्स होते हैं इसके अंदर। तो, समझ
में आ गया कि कांटेक्ट हेडर किस लिए यूज़
किया जाता है? कांटेक्ट हेडर यह बताने के
लिए किया जाता है कि अगर सर्वर मेरे साथ
कांटेक्ट कर रहा है या सर्वर नहीं अगर कोई
मेरे को कॉल करना चाहता है तो वह इन
डिटेल्स के थ्रू कांटेक्ट करेगा जो यहां
पर मैं आपको हाईलाइट कर रहा हूं। उसके बाद
आपका एक्सपायर्स शेडर होता है। एक्सपायर्स
शेडर का मतलब क्या है? कि जो रजिस्ट्रेशन
रिक्वेस्ट आपने भेजी है, इसकी वैलिडिटी
कितनी है? इसकी वैलिडिटी है 300 सेकंड।
मतलब 5 मिनट है। इसका मतलब यह है कि हर 5
मिनट में सर्वर को आपको इस क्लाइंट को
सर्वर के साथ रीजिस्टर करना पड़ेगा। और जब
हर 5 मिनट में रीरजिस्टर करना है तो इसका
मतलब आपका जो सीक्वेंस नंबर है हर 5 मिनट
के बाद तो चेंज होने वाला है। उसमें हर
बार वन इंक्रीमेंट होने वाला ही है
डेफिनेटली। उसके बाद आपका अलऊ मेथड है।
अलऊ मेथड क्या है कि आपको यह बता रहा है
सर्वर को कि जो क्लाइंट है कौन-कौन से
मेथड सपोर्ट करता है। जैसे आपका है प्रैक
है, इनवाइट है, एकनॉलेजमेंट है, बाय है,
कैंसिल है, अपडेट है, इनफो है, सब्सक्राइब
है, नोटिफाई है, रेफरल है, मैसेज ऑप्शन।
इन सारे मेथड को क्या करता है? आपका जो
क्लाइंट है, वह क्या करता है? सपोर्ट करता
है। बता रहा है कि मैं यह मेथड सपोर्ट
करता हूं। मैं आप यह यूज़ कर सकते हो। तो
मैं भी ये यूज़ कर सकता हूं। अपने मेथड बता
दिए। उसके बाद कंटेंट लेंथ जीरो है। मतलब
क्या है? कि कोई भी बॉडी नहीं है। क्योंकि
रजिस्टर मैसेज में कोई भी बॉडी नहीं होती।
तो सबको यह चीज समझ में आ गई?
सबको यह चीज क्लियर है? पहली रिक्वेस्ट
सबको क्लियर है कि जो रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज है
शिप का जो यह वाला जो शिप का यह मैसेज है
यह रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज है इसका किस तरीके के
अंदर इसमें पैकेज या किस तरीके की डिटेल्स
होती है अगर हम उसको एनालाइज करें तो वो
सबको क्लियर हो गया अगर आपको पढ़ने को
मिले आप पढ़ पाओगे आईडिया लगा पाओगे जैसे
रिक्वेस्ट लाइन में क्या होता है मैसेज
हेडर में क्या होता है वाया हेडर में
क्या-क्या चीजें होती हैं फ्रॉम में क्या
होता है टू में क्या होता है कॉलर आईडी
क्यों है कमांड सीक्वेंस और कांटेक्ट यूजर
एजेंट यह एक्सपायर ये सारी चीजें आप समझ
पाओगे एवरीवन प्लीज जल्दी से मुझे बताइए
अगर आप यह लोग समझ पाओगे तो जल्दी से मुझे
आंसर कीजिए चैट में जल्दी से
अगर सबको समझ में आ गया तो हम फिर नेक्स्ट
पर चलते
जल्दी से बताओ दे यार अभी तो स्टूडेंट है
फोर टू फाइव स्टूडेंट है तो जल्दी से बताओ
यह क्लियर है तो हम आगे चलते हैं
हार्ड लग रहा है या इजी लग रहा है यह बताओ
मेरे को आदत पड़ जाएगी बायस में पैकेट
पढ़ने की आप लोगों को
इजी है या हार्ड है बताओ।
ओके।
अभी चलते हैं हम नेक्स्ट पैकेट पे।
नेक्स्ट पैकेट क्या है हमारा?
कॉलर ए ने सर्वर के पास भेजा रजिस्टर
मैसेज। अब उसका रिप्लाई सर्वर ने किया 401
अन ऑथराइज्ड 401 अन ऑथराइज रिप्लाई किया
किसने आपके
सर्वर ने इसका मतलब क्या है जो सिर्फ
सर्वर क्या कर रहा है रजिस्टर मैसेज का
रिप्लाई कर रहा है 4 अन ऑथोराइज्ड अब यह
कोई एरर नहीं है अगर आप शिप के केस में
बात करोगे यह कोई भी एरर नहीं है यह एक
चैलेंज है यहां पर सर्वर क्या बोल रहा है
क्लाइंट को कि कि तुमने रजिस्टर मैसेज तो
सेंड कर दिया लेकिन पासवर्ड नहीं भेजा।
आपने जस्ट ओनली रजिस्टर मैसेज भेजा लेकिन
आपने अभी तक मेरे को पासवर्ड नहीं भेजा।
मतलब आपने मेरे साथ ऑथेंटिकेट नहीं किया
है। तो पहले एक काम कीजिए आप। मैं आपको एक
चैलेंज दे रहा हूं। इस चैलेंज को सॉल्व
करो और उस फिर से आप दोबारा से रजिस्टर
मैसेज भेजो आप। फिर से मेरे पास दोबारा से
रजिस्टर मैसेज भेजो क्योंकि यही शिप के
काम करने का तरीका है। पहली बार जब भी आप
रजिस्टर मैसेज भेजोगे आपको 401 अन
ऑथराइज्ड ही आएगा क्योंकि यही काम करने का
तरीका है शिप का शिप मैसेज का या शिप
प्रोटोकॉल का तो चलिए हम इसको भी एनालाइज
कर लेते हैं। यह आपका देखो शिप स्टेटस
लाइन में क्या है? यह स्टेटस लाइन में
क्या आपका यहां पर हाईलाइट करें तो यहां
पर आपको दिख रहा होगा स्टेटस कोड 401
ओके 401 मतलब क्या है कि दिस इज नॉट एन
एरर सर्वर ने कहा कि ओके मुझे आपका
रजिस्टर मैसेज मिल गया लेकिन आपने एक
वैलिड ऑथेंटिकेशन नहीं भेजा और मुझे वैलिड
ऑथेंटिकेशन नहीं मिला इसलिए मैं आपको क्या
कर रहा हूं एक चैलेंज भेज रहा हूं और यह
बिल्कुल एग्जैक्टली उसी तरीके से काम करता
है अगर आपको पता होगा अगर एचटीटीपी के केस
में जैसे डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन काम करता
है। जैसे डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन काम करता
है। ठीक उसी तरीके से
काम करता है। ओके? तो पहली मैसेज क्या है
आपका? रजिस्टर। उसका ऑलवेज हमेशा रिप्लाई
क्या आएगा? 401। सेकंड रजिस्टर क्या होगा?
आपका 200 ओके के चांसेस होते हैं। और शिप
के केस में आपको बता देता हूं। जो शिप
सर्वर है उसके केस में एज ए सिक्योरिटी
पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से सर्वर कभी भी आपका
पासवर्ड सेंड नहीं करता। दूसरा ना कभी
आपसे प्लेन प्लेन पासवर्ड लेगा। ओके? तो
इसी कारण से क्या करता है? आपको एक
सिक्योरिटी चैलेंज देता है। अब इसको समझते
हैं कि वाया हेडर के अंदर मैसेज हेडर के
अंदर वाया। इसके अंदर क्या है? सेम
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल यूडीपी है। किसने सेंड
किया है? सेंड बाय एड्रेस। इसमें क्या है?
सेंट बाय एड्रेस, सेंट बाय पोर्ट, आर
पोर्ट और रिसीव्ड। मतलब यह आपको बोल रहा
है कि सर्वर आपको बता रहा है कि सर्वर ने
192.168.20.132
को क्या किया है? रिप्लाई सेंड किया है।
किस पोर्ट के ऊपर? 56330 क्योंकि सर्वर
क्लाइंट भी यही चाहता था। और यहां पर जो
रिसीव्ड लिखा हुआ है रिसीव्ड। इसका मतलब
यह है कि यह कंफर्म करता है कि सर्वर ने
किससे मैसेज रिसीव किया था। किससे मैसेज
रिसीव किया था? 192.168.20.132
और यहां पर ब्रांच आईडी देखोगे तो जो
रजिस्टर मैसेज में ब्रांच आईडी थी यह सेम
आईडी है। अगर मैं आपको यह देखो रजिस्टर
मैसेज है नहीं इधर तो इसकी जो ब्रांच आईडी
आप देखोगे पहला रजिस्टर मैसेज यह रहा। तो
इसकी जो ब्रांच आईडी है
Z9HG4 तो सेम उसी अनथराइज के अंदर जो
रजिस्टर आईडी है Z9H सेम4 लास्ट में A19
सेम ब्रांच आईडी यूज़ किया मतलब कुछ भी
चेंज नहीं है पूरी जो रिक्वेस्ट आई थी जो
रजिस्टर मैसेज था उसको रिप्लाई कर दिया
सर्वर ने इसका मतलब है और कॉल आईडी को भी
अगर देखोगे आप यहां पर जो कॉल आईडी है वो
भी सेम है 89 FD 731 और मैं इसे 56 इस
रिक्वेस्ट पे जाता हूं हूं 13 कॉल आईडी भी
क्या है यहां पर 89 FD 731 B24 और सेम 401
में तो मतलब कॉल आईडी भी बिल्कुल सेम है
किसको क्या कह रहा है सेम उसी कॉल आईडी को
रिप्लाई किया है ब्रांच आईडी सेम है कॉल
आईडी सेम है अब यहां पर ध्यान दोगे आप तो
फ्रॉम हेडर देखो फ्रॉम हेडर में क्या है
192 168 20 130 फ्रॉम हेडर में क्या सर्वर
का एड्रेस और ऊपर से देखो टैग टैग आईडी है
517 7 और सेम 517 टैग आईडी किसकी थी? आपकी
जो पहली रिक्वेस्ट थी, जो रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज
था, उसके अंदर जो टैग आईडी जनरेट की गई
थी, मैं आपको बताया था जो रैंडम आईडी थी,
वो सेम यहां पर रखी गई है फ्रॉम मैसेज के
अंदर। अब फ्रॉम में क्या बोल रहा है कि
फ्रॉम में जो वन वन वन वन ने क्या किया?
वो ऑथेंटिकेट करने की कोशिश कर रहा था
इसके साथ। किसके साथ? सर्वर के साथ। यह
टैग आईडी थी। अब टू के अंदर क्या किया?
सर्वर ने शू टू के अंदर सर्वर ने क्या
किया कि फिर से अपना एड्रेस लिखा है। बट
अभी टैग आईडी क्या कर दी? चेंज कर दी।
इसका मतलब क्या है कि सर्वर ने अभी यह
सर्वर के लिए बताया है कि सर्वर ने खुद के
लिए एक टैग आईडी जनरेट कर दी। और यहां पर
इसका मतलब आप समझ सकते हो एक चैलेंज दिया
है सर्वर ने। सर्वर ने क्या किया है? एक
चैलेंज दिया है। तो यहां तक सारी चीज़ आपको
क्लियर होगी। और आप कमांड सीक्वेंस देखोगे
15758 सेम है। कुछ भी चेंज नहीं हुआ। अब
असली कहानी है यह रहा। यही आपका सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट सेक्शन है। यह आपका क्या है?
डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन चैलेंज जो आपके सर्वर
ने भेजा है। किसको? आपके
क्लाइंट को। अब यह देखो ऑथेंटिकेशन स्कीमा
डाइजेस्ट मतलब यह आपका डाइजेस्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन चैलेंज है। रेलम। रेलम का मतलब
क्या होता है? रेलम इक्वल टू इन्हने लिखा
एस्ट्रिक्स। रेलम का मतलब होता है
ऑथेंटिकेशन डोमेन। क्लाइंट को जिस यूजर
नेम और पासवर्ड से लॉगिन करना है, वह इस
रेलम के अकॉर्डिंग क्या होगा? वैलिडेट
होगा। मतलब यह है कि इस डोमेन के अंदर
आपके जो यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड वैलिड होंगे।
जो एस्ट्रिक्स है मतलब क्या है कि जो
सर्वर यूज़ किया जा रहा जो टेक्नोलॉजी यूज़
की जा रही है जो टेक यूज़ की गई है वह
एस्ट्रिक्स की है और इसी के आप यूजरनेम या
पासवर्ड या बात के इसी के क्रेडेंशियल्स
आप यूज़ करोगे इसके अंदर वैलिडेट करने के
लिए किसी और की यूज़ नहीं कर सकते मतलब
आपके पास क्या है रेलम के क्रेडेंशियल
होने चाहिए इसको फॉर एग्जांपल अगर हम रियल
और और की केस बात करें हो सकता है
gmail.com भी हो सकता है facebook.com भी
हो सकता है रेलम तो उसी उसी प्रकार से
यहां पर शिप सर्वर के केस में रेलम क्या
है आपका? एस्ट्रिक्स है। शिप सर्वर के केस
में रेलम क्या है आपका? एस्ट्रिक्स है।
उसके बाद आ गया आपका नॉन्स वैल्यू। अब
नॉनस वैल्यू क्या है? काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
जो ये वैल्यू है इट इज वेरी वेरीेंट।
बिकॉज़ यह क्या है? एक रैंडम टोकन है। यह
क्या है? आपका एक रैंडम टोकन है जिसका यूज़
हैश को जनरेट करने के लिए किया जाता है।
क्योंकि जो यूजर पासवर्ड होगा पासवर्ड कभी
भी प्लेन टेक्स्ट में नहीं भेजा। उसको हैश
की फॉर्म में भेजेगा। तो उसको जनरेट करने
के लिए क्या चाहिए? एक एक नॉन्स वैल्यू
चाहिए। मैं आपको बताऊं कैसे जनरेट होता है
वो भी आपको एक्सप्लेन करूंगा। बट यहां पर
क्या है? ये ये नन्स वैल्यू एक रैंडम टोकन
है जिसका यूज़ किया जाता है आपके#श को
जनरेट करने के लिए। बिल्कुल लाइक जैसे
एचटीटीपी ऑथेंटिकेशन में काम होता है। सेम
उसी तरीके से किस में होता है? आपके शिप
रजिस्टर्स के अंदर भी होता है। ओपेक
वैल्यू। अभी ओपेक वैल्यू क्या है? ओपेक
वैल्यू का मतलब है कि सर्वर एक कोई भी एक
रैंडम वैल्यू भेज रहा है क्लाइंट के पास।
क्लाइंट के पास क्या कर रहा है? कोई भी एक
रैंडम वैल्यू भेज रहा है। जो क्या करना
है? एज इट इज एकको की जाएगी। जो एज इट इज
एकको करनी होती है। किसको? क्लाइंट को
सर्वर के पास। क्लाइंट को सर्वर के पास
एकको करनी होती है। सेम आईडी मतलब सेम
वैल्यू। जब भी आप क्या करो जो नेक्स्ट
रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी यह वैल्यू मैच होनी
चाहिए। यह वैल्यू आपकी मैच होनी चाहिए
क्योंकि एज सिक्योरिटी पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से
अपनी सिक्योरिटी को स्ट्रेंथ करने के लिए।
ओके?
ओके। तो उसके बाद एल्गोरिदम मतलब क्या है
कि यह पासवर्ड हैशिंग एल्गोरििदम को यूज़
किया है MD5 मतलब आपको आपका जो पासवर्ड है
उसके लिए आपको जो एल्गोरिदम यूज़ करनी है
उसका नाम है MD5 उसके बाद क्यूओपी क्या है
क्वालिटी ऑफ़ ये क्या है क्यूओपी आपका
क्वालिटी ऑफ़ प्रोटेक्शन इक्वल टू ओथ इसका
मतलब यह है क्या है कि ऑथेंटिकेशन यहां पर
दो पॉसिबल वैल्यू हो सकती है एक तो ओथ हो
सकती है या ओथ हफन इंट हो सकती है ओथ मतलब
ओनली ऑथेंटिकेशन मतलब आपको अपनी जो
इंटीग्रिटी है वह प्रूव नहीं करनी। यह
होता है ओथ डैश इंट। उसका मतलब क्या होता
है कि ऑथेंटिकेशन प्लस में इंटीग्रिटी।
ओके? तो मोस्टली क्या होता है कि जो
पीबीएक्स सर्वर्स होते हैं जो शिफ्ट
सर्वर्स हैं उनके केस में आपको ओथ ही
देखने को मिलेगा। उसके बाद यह क्या आपका
सर्वर कौन सा सर्वर यूज़ किया जा रहा है?
एफपीबीx उसका वर्जन है और उसके बहुत सारी
चीजें यहां पर थोड़ी डिटेल्स में दी हुई
है। तो यह आपका कंटेंट लेंथ जीरो। तो, यह
यह हेडर आपको क्लियर है?
यह चीजें क्लियर है कि यहां पर क्या हो
रहा है कि 401 अन ऑथराइज मैसेज आया सर्वर
से किसके पास क्लाइंट के पास जहां पर यह
सारी डिटेल्स उस पैकेट में क्या है
क्योंकि यहां पर बेसिकली क्या है कि यह
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है इसमें कि डाइजेस्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोवाइड करना कि एक काम करो
आप मेरे को नेक्स्ट एक और रजिस्टर मैसेज
भेजो लेकिन आपको यह चैलेंज सॉल्व करना मैं
आपको भेज रहा हूं डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंट मतलब
क्या है कि वह आपको ऑथेंटिकेशन आपका
पासवर्ड चाहिए उसके पास क्या करेगा आपके
पासवर्ड का आप पासवर्ड को क्या करोगे आप
हैश फॉर्म में जनरेट करोगे और उसको जनरेट
करने का एक सीक्वेंस है जनरेट करने के बाद
सेम सीक्वेंस में वो जनरेट होगा सर्वर के
पास भी और मैच किया जाएगा दोनों हैश
वैल्यू को अगर वेरीफाई हुआ तो तब देन ओनली
यू गेट द 200 ओके
ओके समझ में आई यह चीज सबको मुझे लगता
लगता है। काफी हार्ड टॉपिक लग रहा है आप
लोगों को
क्योंकि यह काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है। यह आपका
यह सारी वैल्यू मैं आपको बताता हूं
बिल्कुल एक्सप्लेन करना हूं। तो यहां तक
दो ये दो पैकेट क्लियर आप लोगों को जो दो
चीजें क्लियर मुझे लगता है कि आप लोग
सिर्फ यही काम कर पाओगे।
आप सिर्फ यही काम कर पाओगे।
चलिए मुझे लगता है शायद सब ने क्लास छोड़
दिया है। नोबडी इज इन द क्लास।
क्योंकि काफी हार्ड टॉपिक है। ऐसे नहीं
है। व सिक्योरिटी को पेन टेस्ट करना या
वाइब सिक्योरिटी को समझना ऐसी बात नहीं
है। मैं आपको बोर नहीं करने वाला। जस्ट
मेरे को मेरा काम है आप लोगों को ओवरव्यू
देना। सो दैट कि आप ये पैकेट को समझ पाओ
क्योंकि यहां पर हर पॉइंट पर अटैक्स होते
हैं। इसमें दे आर लॉट ऑफ अटैक्स आर
पॉसिबल।
तो इस उसके बाद चलते हैं हम। यह रहा।
नेक्स्ट आपका रजिस्टर मेथड है। रजिस्टर
मेथड से पहले एक और चीज मैं आपको बता देता
हूं कि हम चलते हैं स्लाइड के ऊपर।
हम चलते हैं अपने स्लाइड के ऊपर। और
स्लाइड के ऊपर यह है हमारा नेक्स्ट।
इतने तरीके से कैलकुलेट होता है जब भी यह
डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन कैसे जनरेट होता है
यूजरनेम
रेलम रेलम कौन सा था आपका एस्ट्रिक्स उसके
बाद पासवर्ड इन तीनों की वैल्यू के साथ एक
MD5#श वैल्यू जनरेट की जाती है उसके बाद
मेथड जैसे आपका रजिस्टर मेथड है प्लस में
डाइजेस्ट यूआरआई आपको मैं बताया था ना
वहां पर यूआरआई आती है शिप कॉलन उसके IP
एड्रेस सर्वर का या जिसका भी है तो उन
दोनों को मिला के एक MD5 हैश जनरेट होता
है उसके उसके बाद देखो नाउंस सी नाउंस
क्वालिटी ऑफ प्रोटेक्शन उसके बाद नाउंस
काउंट ये सारी चीजें कुछ चीजें सर्वर्स
सर्वर के रिस्पांस में जो चीजें आई हैं जो
401 अन ऑथराइज के रिस्पांस में जो चीजें
आई हैं कुछ उन चीजों कुछ वो वैल्यू ली
जाती है कुछ वैल्यू खुद से जनरेट की जाती
है और सबको कंबाइन करके हैश जनरेट किए
जाते हैं। यह रहा आपका हैश जनरेट करने की
प्रक्रिया इस तरीके से कि पहले यूजरनेम
रेलम पासवर्ड का एक MD5 मेथड डाइजेस्ट
यूआरएल का एक MD5 वैल्यू उसके बाद नाउंस
काउंट इस MD5 को भी इस MD5 वैल्यू को भी
फिर नाउंस सी नाउंस क्वालिटी इन सबको
मिलाकर फिर एक फाइनल हैश जनरेट किया जाता
है जिस जो आपका हैश किसके अंदर भेजा जाएगा
नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट के अंदर और यही आपका
पासवर्ड होगा जिसको कंपेयर किया जाएगा
क्लियर यही वो हैश वैल्यू जिसको कंपेयर
किया जाएगा।
ये आपकी वो हैश वैल्यू जिसको कंपेयर किया
जाता है।
क्लियर?
अब इसी के बेस पर आपकी नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट
जाएगी।
चलिए फिर हम नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट पर चलते
हैं। और नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट हमारी क्या है?
रजिस्टर रिक्वेस्ट है। फिर से हम चलते
हैं। दिस इज आवर रजिस्टर रिक्वेस्ट। देखो
फिर से रजिस्टर है। यह सेम हेडर है। मेथड
रजिस्टर है। किसने इसको भेजा है?
रिक्वेस्ट यूआरआई सबको क्लियर है। मैं
आपको एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं। मैसेज हेडर
के अंदर सेम यूडीपी है। सेंडर कौन है?
क्लाइंट है। सेम सारी डिटेल्स हैं। अब यह
जो ब्रांच आईडी है, अभी भी सेम रहेगी। यह
जो ब्रांच आईडी है, अभी भी आपकी सेम होगी।
क्योंकि
यह किसका पार्ट है? पहली रिक्वेस्ट का
पार्ट है। इसीलिए जो आपकी ब्रांच आईडी है,
कॉल आईडी है, कुछ या टैग है, इवन यह सारी
चीजें आपकी सेम ही होगी। ओके? आपको सेम
देखने जब आप देखोगे आपको सेम देखने को
मिलेंगे। क्योंकि जो आपकी पहली रिक्वेस्ट
गई थी जो रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस था जो
रजिस्टर रिस्पांस था जो पहली रजिस्टर
मैसेज गया था यह सेम उसी को दोबारा भेजा
गया है बट यह इसकी ऑथेंटिकेटेड रिक्वेस्ट
है दैट इज व्हाई जो आपकी ब्रांच है ब्रांच
की यूनिक आईडी है और उसके बाद आपकी कॉल
आईडी है हम बात करें जो टैग भी है यह जो
कॉल आईडी भी है यह लगभग यह सारी सेम
रहेंगी इस रिक्वेस्ट में भी तो उसके बाद
देखोगे फ्रॉम मैसेज क्या है सेम वही है
फ़्रॉम मैसेज भी टू मैसेज भी सेम
सेम जैसे कि हम पहली रिक्वेस्ट गई थी
कमांड सीक्वेंस देखो अब की बार बढ़ गया
157 पहले 58 था 157 159 क्योंकि फिर से
हमने रजिस्टर मैसेज भेजा है उसमें प्लस वन
काउंट हो गया यूजर एजेंट सेम है कांटेक्ट
डिटेल्स वही सेम है उसके बाद एक्सपरेशन यह
मेथड है यह है वह ऑथराइजेशन हेडर जिसकी हम
बात कर रहे हैं जो एक नई चीज ऐड हुई है जो
पहली रिक्वेस्ट में नहीं थी जो आपकी पहली
रिक्वेस्ट में नहीं थी जो इस रिक्वेस्ट
में है यह है वह चीज़। देखो यहां पर क्या
है? इसका मतलब मैं आपको समझाता हूं
क्योंकि यह समझना यूज़रनेम कौन सा आपका?
शिप अकाउंट है। 11 1 रेलम देखो ऑथेंटिकेशन
डाइजेस्ट है। यूजरनेम है। रेलम आपको पता
है एस्ट्रिक्स का यूज़ किया है। यह आपकी
अनाउंस वैल्यू है। यह कौन सी अनाउंस
वैल्यू है? सेम अनाउंस वैल्यू है। जो किस
में यूज़ की गई थी? आपके लास्ट पैकेट के
अंदर जो 401 अन ऑथराइज़्ड जो पैकेट था यह
वाला पैकेट था। यह रहा ऊपर। इसमें जो
वैल्यू थी, अगर मैं इसको वैल्यू दिखाऊंगा।
ये रही इसकी अनाउंस वैल्यू ये थी 152 वाली
लास्ट में 262 ये रही सेम इसमें है कहां
गई ये रहा 152 सेम अनाउंस वैल्यू है
क्योंकि यह सेम होनी चाहिए इसी के बेस
पे#श कंप्यूट किए गए हैं इसी के बेस पे#श
जनरेट किए गए हैं और इसी बेस पर जो
नेक्स्ट हैश है जो सर्वर के अंदर है उसको
कंपेयर किया जाएगा ऑथेंटिकेशन यूआरआई
क्यों क्योंकि यह भी जरूरी है क्योंकि यह
भी किसके अंदर जब हम हैश कैलकुलेट कर रहे
थे अभी आपको मैंने एक फार्मूला दिखाया था
डाइजेस्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन का जब वह हम कैलकुलेट
करे थे। इसका भी यूज़ किया गया है उसके
अंदर। आपने देखा होगा कि डाइजेस्ट यरी
प्लस में मेथड मेथड तो दो चीज मिला के तब
जाके ये काउंट हो रहा था। दैट इज़ व्हाई।
उसके बाद यह आपका एक्चुअल हैश है। जो मैं
आपको बताया था यहां पर यह हैश रिस्पांस
डाइजेस्ट है। यह जो आपका रिस्पांस
डाइजेस्ट है, यह यही है। जो फाइनल आपको
हैश वैल्यू मिली थी आपके पासवर्ड की। यही
वह आपकी फाइनल MD5s है जो यह प्रूव करेगा
कि क्लाइंट को अपना पासवर्ड पता है
और यह एक वैलिड पासवर्ड है या इनवैलिड
पासवर्ड है। उसके बाद एल्गोरििदम MD5 सी
अनाउंस वैल्यू सी अनाउंस वैल्यू आपको पता
है यह क्लाइंट ने खुद से एक रैंडम जनरेट
की है। यह आईडी क्लाइंट ने खुद से जनरेट
की है। किसी ने जनरेट नहीं की। क्लाइंट ने
खुद से जनरेट की है। उसके बाद ओपेक
वैल्यू। ओपेक वैल्यू क्या है कि ओपेक
वैल्यू यह वही सेम वैल्यू है जो किस में
मैंने आपको बोला बताया था कि सर्वर ने
भेजा है और यह वैल्यू क्लाइंट के एक को
होनी चाहिए। क्लाइंट की रिक्वेस्ट में
होनी चाहिए। यह क्लाइंट की होनी चाहिए।
उसके बाद क्यूओपी क्वालिटी ऑफ़ प्रोटेक्शन
क्या है? ओथ सेम है। नाउंस काउंट अब की
बार ऐड हुआ है वन। नाउंस काउंट क्या होता
है? फर्स्ट टाइम अभी क्लाइंट ने जनरेट
किया है क्योंकि इसका यूज़ तब किया जाएगा
क्योंकि आपको पता है इसके अंदर एक
एक्सपायरी टाइम सेट है 300 मतलब पांच हर 5
मिनट में उसको रीरजिस्टर करना पड़ेगा उस
टाइम पे हर बार इसको क्या करना पड़ेगा फिर
ये बाउंस काउंट बढ़ेगा क्योंकि फर्स्ट टाइम
है तो सेकंड टाइम में टू होगा थर्ड टाइम
में थ्री होगा फोर्थ टाइम में फोर होगा तो
अभी ये फर्स्ट टाइम जनरेट हुआ है इसलिए ये
वन है
क्या हो गया बोर हो गए सीरीज से ये सिर्फ
पूछ रहे हो कितने दिन ये सीरीज चलेगी बोर
हो गए आप लोग
यार इतना स्पैम मत करो ना
पागल हो यार आप लोग भी
ठीक है तो यह चीज क्लियर है सबको
यह भी क्लियर है शायद आप लोगों को उसके
बाद जो मैसेज है नेक्स्ट आपका नेक्स्ट
मैसेज 200 ओके नेक्स्ट मैसेज आपका है 200
ओके नेक्स्ट मैसेज आपका क्या है 200 ओके
मैसेज
आपका क्या है? 200 ओके मतलब इसको आप
देखोगे तो यह रहा ओके है। स्टेटस कोड 200
ओके है। मतलब 200 ओके का मतलब क्या है?
200 ओके का मतलब यह है कि ऑथेंटिकेशन
सक्सेसफुल हो गया है। आपने जो डाइजेस्ट
भेजे थे वह करेक्ट है। आप ऑफिशियली
रजिस्टर हो चुके हो। अब आपको आपके पास हम
कॉल फॉरवर्ड कर सकते हैं। अगर आपके लिए
कोई कॉल आएगी तो यही है।
कॉल आएगी तो हम फॉरवर्ड कर सकते हैं। देखो
यहां पे देखोगे सेम ट्रांसपोर्ट यूडीपी ये
चीज वो वो ब्रांच आईडी सब सेम है। यह सारी
हेड आप लोगों को क्लियर मैं आपको अभी बोर
नहीं करूंगा। ये चीज आप देखोगे आपको
क्लियर हो जाएगा। और इसके ऊपर आर्टिकल तो
आपको मिलने वाले हैं काफी डिटेल्स में।
आर्टिकल्स आप लोगों को मिलने ही वाले हैं।
उसके बाद एक और चीज़ ऐड हुई। इसमें डेट।
डेट का मतलब क्या है कि जो सर्वर है आपका
जो शिप सर्वर है उसका क्या है टाइम स्टैंप
यहां पर ऐड हो गया है जिसका काम जो किस
लिए यूज़ किया जाएगा आपका लॉगिन या
सिक्योरिटी के लिए यूज़ किया जाता है तो आई
होप कि मैंने आपको चार रिक्वेस्ट समझा दिए
यह रही कि रजिस्टर रिक्वेस्ट उसके बाद 4
वन अनऑथराइज्ड यह भेजा ही भेजा है उसके
बाद ऑथेंटिकेटेड रिक्वेस्ट 200 ओके मतलब
आप रजिस्टर हो गए अभी इन पे ध्यान देने की
ऑप्शन नोटिफाई इन पे ध्यान देने की आपको
जरूरत नहीं है तो यह था जब कॉलर ए ने
सर्वर के साथ रजिस्टर किया। सेम काम क्या
हुआ? जब कॉलर बी ने भी सर्वर के साथ
रजिस्टर क्योंकि अभी मैं कॉलर बी को तभी
कॉल कर सकता हूं जब वह रजिस्टर होगा। तो
इसलिए वह भी रजिस्टर करता है। तो उसने
रजिस्टर मैसेज किया सर्वर ने 401 अन
ऑथराइज फिर उसने रजिस्टर मैसेज किया 200
होके मैसेज मिला। देन दोनों जो कॉलर हैं
रजिस्टर हो गए। कौन सा? 11 1 तो फोर टाइम
वन है एक टू फोर टाइम्स टू है। दोनों कॉलर
रजिस्टर हो गए। मतलब अब आपस में यह कॉल कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि इनकी जो इंफॉर्मेशन है
वह सर्वर के पास है। मैं क्या कर रहा हूं?
मैं कभी भी डायरेक्ट ए से बी को कॉल नहीं
कर सकता। मैं डायरेक्ट किसको कॉल कर सकता
हूं? मैं बोलूंगा कि सर्वर को कि मुझे बी
को कॉल करना है। तो यह मेरी कॉल को
फॉरवर्ड करेगा। गाइज क्लियर है
यार। इतना स्पैम मत करो यार। चीजें पूछने
के लिए आप अपने मैसेज तो बंद करो यार।
मैं कुछ पूछने के लिए आप अपने मैसेज कट
कॉपी पेस्ट करते रहते हो यार।
तो ये चीज सबको क्लियर है यहां तक
रजिस्टर रिक्वेस्ट सबको क्लियर है। मुझे
लगता है आप इसी में बोर होगे आज।
ओनली रजिस्टर प्रैक्टिकल क्लियर है कि अगर
आपको मैं कोई भी
वही पैकेट देता हूं सीट पैकेट तो आप देख
के पता कर पाओगे कहां कैसे रजिस्ट्रेशन हो
रहा है
कैसे रजिस्ट्रेशन अब पता कर पाओगे आप लोग
कर पाओगे आप लोग
आई एम नॉट स्ट्रगलिंग ब्रो ऑल ऑफ यू आर
स्ट्रगलिंग
या आई एम श्योर मैं इनको प्रोवाइड
प्रोवाइड करूंगा अपने उसके अंदर आर्टिकल
के अंदर
तो यह थी आपकी अभी एक चीज और आपको दिखाता
हूं। मैं इसको पहले क्लोज करता हूं। एक और
चीज है। मैं इसको एक बार क्लोज किया।
सेव कर देते हैं। अभी के लिए अभी मैं एक
काम करता हूं। अगर रजिस्ट्रेशन फेल हुआ तो
किस तरीके की आपको रिक्वेस्ट दिखेंगी? चलो
मैं इसको भी डबल क्लिक करता हूं। वसआर के
अंदर ओपन करता हूं। यह रहा। यह यह है आपकी
रजिस्ट्रेशन फेल वाली। तो मैं टेलीफ़ोनी
शिफ्ट फ्लो कंट्रोल ऑल और इसको हम क्या
करते हैं? फॉलो सीक्वेंस। ये देखो
ये रजिस्ट्रेशन फेल है। यूजर वन सर्वर के
साथ देखो रजिस्टर मैसेज किया 401 अन
ऑथराइज रजिस्टर मैसेज 401 अन ऑथराइज
रजिस्टर 401 मतलब क्या है कि पहली
रिक्वेस्ट आपको एनालाइज करते हैं। देखो
आपको आईडिया मिल जाएगा क्योंकि इनकरेक्ट
पासवर्ड भी तो हो सकता है ना। देखो सेम है
रिक्वेस्ट लाइन है।
मैसेज हेडर है। पहले में रिक्वेस्ट में
कुछ भी नहीं था। कॉल नहीं। उसके बाद क्या
हुआ? 40 अन ऑथराइज। देन यह देखोगे यहां पर
ऑथेंटिकेशन चैलेंज दिया है। उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट भेजी रजिस्टर उसमें
इन्होंने क्या किया? डाइजेस्ट भेजा है।
देखो यहां देखोगे यह रहा डाइजेस्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन। यह आपकी हैश वैल्यू है। बट यह
सही नहीं होगा। पासवर्ड रॉन्ग होगा। इसलिए
फिर से इसके रिप्लाई में क्या आया? फिर से
इन्होंने डाइजेस्ट चैलेंज दिया क्योंकि
नहीं मैं आपको फिर से आपको एक और डाइजेस्ट
चैलेंज करता हूं। सॉल्व करो। फिर से एक और
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी। फिर से इन्होंने क्या
किया?
अन ऑथराइज कर दिया। रिक्वेस्ट फिर से
भेजी। देखो यह रहा। देन उसके बाद देखो अन
ऑथराइज़ फिर से देखो रजिस्टर करने को किया।
ऐसे तो मतलब यह मल्टीपल्स अन ऑथराइज़्ड
एक्सेस आती गई क्योंकि यह फ़ेलियर मैसेज
है। क्योंकि पासवर्ड सही नहीं रहोगे तब तक
यह चलता रहेगा। यह चीज भी आपको दिखा दिया
कि अगर आपके पासवर्ड रोंग्स होते हैं तो
किस तरह की रिक्वेस्ट आपको देखने को मिल
रही।
बिल्कुल मैं उधर ही शेयर कर दूंगा फाइलें।
अगर आप डाउनलोड कर पाओगे तो
यह मैं बता दूंगा। फिर ग्रुप में शेयर
करवा दूंगा फाइलें आपकी प्रैक्टिस के लिए।
WhatsApp चैनल के ग्रुप में।
तो यहां तक सारी चीजें क्लियर है सबको? ये
दोनों प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल क्लियर हो गया
आप लोगों को।
आगे करना है आज इतना ही करवा दूं क्योंकि
मुझे पता है काफी हार्ड है जो मैंने आपको
समझाने की कोशिश की क्योंकि हर एक पैकेट
को एनालाइज करना हर पैकेट को समझना नॉट एन
इजी जॉब बट अब हम धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ रहे
हैं। हमने रजिस्ट्रेशन का प्रैक्टिकल देख
लिया। उसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले हैं कि
जो सिर्फ फ्लो है, सिर्फ हैंडशक है, उसको
भी देखने वाले हैं। उसको भी देख लेंगे।
उसके बाद ऑडियो एनालिसिस पर हम फिर
फॉरवर्ड आगे बढ़ जाएंगे। सो दैट कि आपको
और भी ज्यादा चीजें क्लियर हो जाए।
तो आज का प्रैक्टिकल आई होप कि सबके लिए
काफी होगा
और आई होप कि सबको मजा भी आया होगा इस
प्रैक्टिकल में।
बताओ
क्योंकि ज्यादा करवाऊंगा फिर वही है ना आप
लोगों के ऊपर से जाएगा और आप लोगों को समझ
में ही नहीं आएगा तो क्या फायदा फिर
बताओ कोई फायदा है
बताओ
कोई भी फायदा है तो बताओ।
धीरे-धीरे थोड़े-थोड़े कांसेप्ट पढ़ते
जाएंगे तो आप लोगों के लिए चीजें क्लियर
होती जाएंगी। आप लोगों के डाउट्स भी
क्लियर हो जाएंगे और आप लोगों को ज्यादा
प्रॉब्लम भी क्रिएट नहीं होगी और चीजें
बहुत ही आसानी से आप कर भी पाओगे।
और किसी का कोई डाउट है मुझसे पूछना चाहते
हो या रिलेटेड टू द क्लास रिलेटेड टू द
कांसेप्ट आप पूछ सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है।
पूछना चाहते हो कुछ?
समझा नहीं क्या बोल रहे हो आप
और जिसको कोई भी आईडिया नहीं है आप किसकी
बात कर रहे हो 143
तो अगर किसी का कोई भी सवाल नहीं है तो हम
क्लास को एंड कर सकते हैं फिर
हां नेक्स्ट सेशन के लिए मैं आपको विनोद
बता देता हूं। थोड़ा सा अब की बार मुझे
टाइम लगेगा बिकॉज़ मैं ट्रैवल कर रहा हूं
और ड्यूरिंग ट्रैवल मैं क्लास नहीं ले
सकता तो मे बी दिस टाइम योर नेक्स्ट सेशन
विल बी ऑन
मे बी ऑन थर्सडे बिफोर थर्सडे नो सेशन
बिकॉज़ आई एम ट्रैवलिंग
टॉपिक कंटिन्यू रहेगा
देखो मैंने एक सेक्शन स्टार्ट किया है व
सिक्योरिटी है वप एंड टेस्टिंग तो वप के
ऊपर बहुत सारी क्लासेस आएंगी क्योंकि
धीरे-धीरे हमें क्या करना है टू वे
कम्युनिकेशन की ऑडियो फाइल को भी देखना है
ऑडियो फाइल को चेक करना है इसके पासवर्ड
क्रैक करके भी देखना है इन सारी चीजों को
अभी क्या कर रहे हैं आप विनोद आप क्या कर
रहे हो
यू आर लर्निंग व पे टेस्टिंग ना
हम उसी सेक्शन में होंगे ना या कहीं दूसरे
सेक्शन में है द पार्ट थ्री ऑफ वाइप एंड
टेस्टिंग पार्ट थ्री है ना
या कुछ अलग है हमारे सेशन का नाम बताइए
बताओ विनोद
तुम तो रेगुलर हो यार क्लास में फिर भी आप
ऐसा सवाल पूछ रहे हो
राइट गॉट इट।
चलिए फिर नेक्स्ट सेशन हम थर्सडे को लेंगे
और इसको कंटिन्यू करेंगे कि हम सिर्फ फ्लो
देखेंगे और एक्सट्रैक्शन ऑफ ऑडियो फाइल।
ओके फर्स्ट चैलेंज हम देखेंगे ऑडियो फाइल
कैसे एक्सट्रैक्ट करते हैं कन्वर्जेशन के
बीच में दो पार्टीज के बीच में उसके बाद
धीरे-धीरे हम आगे बढ़ेंगे तो ऐसे ही हमारी
विक कई क्लासेस आएंगी तो तब तक के लिए
बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड
सी यू फॉर थर्सडे सेशन बाय बाय एंड गुड
नाइट एवरीवन